la gran dama como bodega para vinificar
vino su primera cosecha es un merlot la
bodega fue instalada en el primer piso
de la torre eiffel en octubre de 2019
ahora es tiempo de degustarlo mucha
elegancia y delicadeza con un modesto
grado de alcohol lo que lo hace muy
fácil de beber de taninos precisos y
bien definidos que se integran muy bien
en el paladar
aquí mismo se embotella cada ejemplar
sólo unos pocos fueron convidados al
descorche de las primeras botellas de
este vino tinto orgánico han llegado a
57 metros de altura cuando hablamos de
parís de francia hablamos de la torre
eiffel
cuando hablamos de francia hablamos de
vino entonces cuando nos propusieron a
níjar vino en la torre eiffel en seguida
nos pareció una idea muy original
original la apuesta del dom en la
burbuja es producir en parís un vino de
gran calidad asociando sus viñedos en
versalles al monumento más visitado del
mundo para conjugar turismo y enología
nuestro deseo era crear una bodega
funcional que permita crear un vino a la
altura de su reputación luego vinifica
mos la uva en estas barricas hechas a la
medida del montacargas de la torre
eiffel y que fueron instaladas
especialmente para crear la bodega de la
torre eiffel son cubas en forma de
tronco para vinificar con cuidado este
malo
en 2020 sólo saldrán 300 botellas del
pse de la tour eiffel vendidas en
estuche de lujo por 80 euros cada una
sólo podrán ser adquiridas en selectas
cavas parisinas